is
but uh
that is
okay
she's
that's so cute
sounds good we need to do the escort
committee
yeah yeah
guys
good
are you ready
[Music]
the joint session will come to order
the chair appoints as members of the
committee
on the part of the house to escort the
president of the united states
into the chamber the gentleman from
maryland mr hoyer
the gentleman from south carolina mr
clyburn
the gentlewoman from massachusetts ms
clark
the gentleman from new york mr jefferies
the gentleman from california mr aguilar
the gentlewoman from delaware ms blunt
rochester
the gentleman from california mr
mccarthy
the gentlewoman from wyoming miss cheney
the gentleman from oklahoma mr cole
the gentleman from texas mr brady of the
gentleman from utah mr owens
and the gentleman the gentlewoman from
iowa
mrs miller meeks
the president of the senate at the
direction of that body appoints the
following senators
as members of the committee on the part
of the senate
to escort the president of the united
states into the house chamber
the senator from new york mr schumer the
senator from vermont mr nehe
the senator from illinois mr durbin
the senator from michigan ms stabenow
the senator from vermont mr sanders
the senator from minnesota ms klobuchar
the senator from kentucky mr mcconnell
the senator from south dakota mr thune
the senator from wyoming mr barrasso
the senator from iowa miss ernst
the senator from missouri mr blunt
the senator from florida mr scott
the members of the escort committee will
exit the chamber through the lobby doors
the right and left of the speaker's
coding
escort committee has headed out
sure
is
when do we announce this other
is that
you know what i said
[Music]
yeah but it's causing a hell of a lot of
breach
as well
[Music]
i saw your texts
tv ad you got to see his ad man who is
the best dad
although i gotta tell you like in my
district
[Music]
i know
oh
madam speaker the dean of the diplomatic
[Applause]
corps
when
yes
is
madam speaker the chief justice of the
supreme court
[Applause]
which
[Applause]
it takes like years
madam speaker representatives of the
president's cabinet
[Applause]
here
i don't know what to do
oh
it's hard to disappoint me
i love you guys
great job
still got a few more
[Applause]
okay we are already in the chamber the
escort committee is taking the place
somewhere elliot angle is upset yes
you wait all day no yeah
that was just you peter
madam speaker the president of the
united states
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
so
[Applause]
[Applause]
members of congress i have the high
privilege
and distinct honor to present to you
the president of the united states
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
thank you thank you thank you
good to be back
[Applause]
mitch and chuckle understand is good to
be almost home
down the hall anyway thank you all madam
speaker
madam vice president
no president has ever said those words
from this podium no president has ever
said those words
and it's about time
[Applause]
first lady and her husband
second gentleman
chief justice
members of the united states congress
and the cabinet distinguished guests
my fellow americans while the
setting tonight is familiar this
gathering
is just a little bit different a
reminder of the extraordinary times
we're in
throughout our history presidents have
come to this chamber to speak to
congress
to the nation and of the world to
declare war
to celebrate peace to announce new plans
and possibilities
tonight i come to talk about crisis
and opportunity about rebuilding the
nation
revitalizing our democracy and winning
the future
for america i stand here tonight
one day shy of the hundredth day of my
administration
100 days since i took the oath of office
and lifted my hand
off our family bible and inherited a
nation
we all did that was in crisis the worst
pandemic in a century
the worst economic crisis since the
great depression
the worst attack on our democracy since
the civil war
now after just 100 days
i can report to the nation america
is on the move again
turning parallel into possibility
crisis to opportunity setbacks and the
strength
we all know life can knock us down
but in america we never ever ever
stay down americans always get up
today that's what we're doing america is
rising anew
choosing hope over fear truth over lies
and light over darkness
after 100 days of rescue and renewal
america is ready for a takeoff in my
view
we're working again dreaming again
discovering again and leading the world
again
we have shown each other and the world
that there's no
quit in america none
100 days ago america's house was on fire
we had to act and thanks the
extraordinary leadership of
speaker pelosi majority leader schumer
and the overwhelming support of the
american people democrats independents
and republicans
we did act together we passed the
american rescue plan
one of the most consequential rescue
packages in american history
we're already seeing the results
we're already seeing the results
[Applause]
after i promised we'd get 100 million
covet 19 vaccine shots
into people's arms in 100 days we will
have provided
over 220 million coveted shots
in those 100 days thanks to all the help
of all of you
[Applause]
we're marshaling with your help
everyone's help we're marshaling every
federal resource
we've gotten vaccines nearly 40 000
pharmacies
and over 700 community health centers
where the poorest of the poor can be
reached
we're setting up community vaccination
sites
developing mobile units to get the hard
to reach
communities today
ninety percent of americans now live
within five miles of a vaccination site
everyone over the age of 16
everyone is now eligible to get
vaccinated
right now right away go get
vaccinated america go and get the
vaccination
they're available
[Applause]
you're eligible now
when i was sworn in on january 20th less
than one percent of the seniors in
america are fully vaccinated against
coba 19.
100 days later 70
of seniors in america over 65 are
protected fully protected
senior deaths from cover 19 are down 80
since january down 80 percent because of
all of you
and more than half of all the adults in
america have gotten at least one shot
a mass vaccination center in glendale
arizona
i asked the nurse
i said what's it like she looked at me
and she said
it's like every shot is giving a dose of
hope
as a phrase a dose of hope a dose of
hope for an educator in florida
was a child suffering from an autoimmune
disease
wrote to me said she's worried that she
was worried about bringing the virus
home
she said she then got vaccinated at a
large site
in her car she said she sat in her car
when she got vaccinated just cried
cried out of joy and cried out of relief
parents seeing the smiles on the kids
faces for those who are able to go back
to school
because the teachers and school bus
drivers and cafeteria workers have been
vaccinated
grandparents hugging their children and
grandchildren instead of pressing hands
against the window
to say goodbye means everything
those things mean everything you know
they're still
you all know it you know it better than
any group of americans
there's still more work to do to beat
this virus
we can't let our guard down but tonight
i can say because of you
the american people
our progress these past hundred days
against one of the worst pandemics in
history
has been one of the greatest logistical
achievements
logistical achievements this country's
ever seen
what else have we done in those first
hundred days
we kept our commitment democrats and
republicans
i'm sending 1400 rescue checks to 85
percent of american households
we're already sent more than once 160
million checks out the door
it's making the difference you all know
when you go home
for many people it's making all the
difference in the world
a single mom in texas who wrote me she
said
she couldn't work but she said the
relief check
put food on the table and saved her and
her son
from eviction from their apartment
a grandmother in virginia who told me
she immediately took her granddaughter
to the eye doctor
something she said she put off for
months because she didn't have the money
one of the defining images at least from
my perspective in this crisis has been
cars lined up cars lined up for
miles and not
not people just barely ever start those
cars nice cars
lined up for miles waiting for a box of
food to be put
in their trunk i don't know about you
but i didn't ever think i'd see that in
america
and all of this is through no fault of
their own
man no fault of their own
these people are in this position
that's why the rescue plan is delivering
food and nutrition assistance to
millions of americans facing hunger
it hungers down sharply already
we're also providing rental assistance
you all know this
the american people i want to make sure
they understand
keeping people from being evicted from
their homes
providing loans to small businesses that
reopen
and keep their employees on the job
during these hundred days an additional
eight
hundred thousand americans enrolled in
the affordable care act
when i established a special sign-up
period to do that eight hundred thousand
in that period we're making one of the
largest one-time
ever investments ever in improving
health care for veterans
critical investments to address the
opioid crisis
and maybe most importantly thanks to the
american rescue plan we're on track
to cut child poverty in america in half
this year
[Applause]
in the process
[Applause]
all this is all going on the economy
created
more than 1 million 300 000 new jobs in
100 days
more jobs with first
more jobs in the first hundred days than
any
president on record the international
monetary fund
the international monetary fund
is now estimating our economy will grow
at a rate of more than six percent this
year
that'll be the fastest pace of economic
growth in this country in nearly four
decades
america's moving moving forward
but we can't stop now we're in
competition with china and other
countries
to win the 21st century we're at a great
inflection point
in history we have to do more than just
build back better
we build back we have to build back
better we have to compete
more strenuously than we have throughout
our history
we think about it public investment and
infrastructure
has literally transformed america our
attitudes as well as our opportunities
the transcontinental railroad the
interstate highways
united two oceans and brought a totally
new age of progress
to the united states of america
universal public schools and college aid
opened wide the doors of opportunity
scientific breakthroughs took us to the
moon
now we're on mars discovering vaccines
gave us the internet
and so much more
these are investments we made together
as one country
in investments that only the government
was in a position to make
time and again they propel us into the
future
that's why i propose the american jobs
plan
a once-in-a-generation investment in
america itself
this is the largest jobs plan since
world war ii
creates jobs to upgrade our
transportation infrastructure
jobs modernizing our roads bridges
highways
jobs building ports and airports rail
carters transit lines
it's clean water and today
up to 10 million homes in america and
more than 400
000 schools and child care centers
have pipes with lead in them including
drinking water
a clear and present danger to our
children's health
american jobs plan creates jobs
replacing
100 percent of the nation's lead pipes
and service lines
so every american can drink
clean water
and the process will create thousands
and thousands of good paying jobs
it creates jobs connecting every
american with high-speed internet
including 35 percent of the rural
america that still
doesn't have it it's going to help our
kids
and our businesses succeed in the 21st
century economy
and i'm asking the vice president to
lead this effort if she would
because i know get done
creates jobs building a modern power
grid
our grids are vulnerable to storms hacks
catastrophic failures with tight tragic
results
as we saw in texas and elsewhere during
the winter storms
the american jobs plan will create jobs
that lay thousands of miles of
transmission lines needed
to build a resilient and fully clean
grid
we can do that
[Applause]
look american jobs plan
will help millions of people get back to
their jobs
and back to their careers
two million women have dropped out of
the workforce during this pandemic
two million and too often because they
couldn't get the care they needed
to care for their child or care for an
elderly parent
who needs help
800 000 families around the medicare
waiting list right now
to get home care for their aging parent
or loved one with disability if you
think it's not important
check out in your own district democrat
or republican
democrat or republican voters
their great concern almost as much as
the children is taking care
of an elderly loved one who can't be
left alone
medicaid contemplated but this plan is
going to help those families
and create jobs for our caregivers with
better wages and better benefits
continuing to cycle growth for too long
we fail to use the most important word
when it comes to meeting the climate
crisis
jobs jobs
job
[Applause]
for me when i think climate change i
think
jobs american jobs plan will put
engineers and construction workers to
work building more energy efficient
buildings and homes
electrical workers ibew members
installing 500
000 charging stations along our highways
so we can own
so we can own the electric car market
farmers farmers planting cover crops
so they can reduce the carbon dioxide in
the air and get paid for doing
it look
think about it there is simply no reason
why the blades for wind turbines can't
be built in pittsburgh instead of
beijing
no reason none
no reason
but folks
there's no reason why american american
workers
can't lead the world in the production
of electric vehicles and batteries
i mean there is no reason you have the
capacity
you're the brightest best trained people
in the world
the american jobs plan is going to
create millions of good paying jobs jobs
americans can raise a family on
as my dad would then say with a little
breathing room
and all the investments in the american
job plan will be guided by one principle
by american by america
and i might note parenthetically
that does not that does not violate any
trade agreement
it's been the law since the 30s buy
america
american tax dollars are going to be
used to buy american products
made in america to create american jobs
that's the way it's supposed to be and
it will be in this administration
and i made it clear to all my cabinet
people
their ability to give exemptions has
been
extraneously limited it will be american
products
now i know some of you at home are
wondering
whether these jobs are for you
so many of you so many of the folks i
grew up with
feel left behind forgotten in an economy
that's so
rapidly changing it's frightening
i want to speak directly to you because
you think about it
what people are most worried about can i
fit in
independent experts estimate the
american jobs family add
millions of jobs and trillions of
dollars to economic growth in the years
to come
it is a it is a eight-year program
these are good-paying jobs that can't be
outsourced
nearly 90 percent of the infrastructure
jobs created in an american jobs plan
do not require a college degree
75 percent don't require an associate's
degree
american jobs plan is a blue collar
blueprint
to build america that's what it is
and it recognizes something i've always
said
in this chamber and the other
good guys and women on wall street but
wall street didn't build this country
the middle class built the country and
unions built the middle class
so that's why i'm calling on congress
to pass protect the right to organize
act the pro act and send it to my desk
so we can support the right to unionize
[Applause]
and by the while way thinking about
sending things to my desk
let's raise the minimum wage to 15
no one
no one working 40 hours a week
no one working 40 hours a week should
live below the poverty line
we need to ensure greater equity and
opportunity for women and while we're
doing this let's get the paycheck
fairness act to my desk as well
equal pay it's been much too long
and if you wonder whether it's too long
look behind me
and finally american jobs plan will be
the biggest increase in non-defense
research and development on record
we'll see more technological change
and some of you know more about this
than i do
we'll see more technological change in
the next 10 years than we saw in the
last 50
that's how rapidly
artificial intelligence and so much more
is changing
and we're falling behind the competition
with the rest of the world
decades ago we used to invest two
percent of our gross domestic product
in america two percent of our gross
domestic product
research and development today
mr secretary that's less than one
percent
china and other countries are closing in
fast
we have to develop and dominate the
products and technologies of the future
advanced batteries biotechnology
computer chips clean energy
the secretary of defense can tell you
and those you on
work on national security issues now the
defense department has an agency called
darpa
the defense advanced research project
agency
the people who set up before i came here
and that's been a long time ago
to develop breakthroughs that enhance
our national security
that's their only job and it's a
semi-separate agency it's under the
defense department
it's led to everything from the
discovery of the internet
to gps and so much more it's enhanced
our security
the national institute of health the nih
i believe
should create a similar advanced
research
projects agency for health
and that would here's what it would do
it would have a singular purpose to
develop breakthroughs
to prevent detect and treat diseases
like alzheimer's
diabetes and cancer
i'll still never forget when we passed
the cancer proposal last year as vice
president
almost nine million dollars going to nih
they've excused the point of personal
privilege not forget you standing mitch
and saying name and after my deceased
son
it meant a lot but so many of us
had to see sons daughters and relatives
who died of cancer
i can think of no more worthy investment
i know of nothing that is more
bipartisan
so let's end cancer as we know it it's
within our power
it's within our power to do it
[Applause]
investments in jobs and infrastructure
like the ones we're talking about
have often had bipartisan support in the
past
vice president harris and i met
regularly in the oval office with
democrats and republicans discussed the
jobs plan
and i applaud a group of republican
senators who just put forward their own
proposal
so let's get to work i wanted to lay out
before the congress my plan
before we got into the deep discussions
i like to meet with those who have ideas
that
are different they think are better
i welcome those ideas but the rest of
the world is not waiting for us
i just want to be clear from my
perspective doing nothing
is not an option
[Applause]
look
we can't be so busy competing with one
another
that we forget the competition that we
have with the rest of the world to win
the 21st century
secretary blinken can tell you i spent a
lot of time with president xi
traveled over 17 000 miles with him
spent the time over 24 hours in private
discussions with him
when he called to congratulate him we
had a two-hour discussion
he's deadly earnest
about becoming the most significant
consequential nation in the world
he and others
autocrats think that democracy can't
compete in the 21st century
with autocracies because it takes too
long to get consensus
to win that competition for the future
in my view we also need to make a
once-in-a-generation investment
in our families and our children
that's why i've introduced the american
families plan tonight
which addresses four of the biggest
challenges facing american families and
in turn america
first is access to good education
when this nation made 12 years of public
education universal
in the last century it made us the best
educated
best prepared nation in the world it's i
believe the overwhelming reason that
propelled us to where we
got in the 21st and the 20th century
but the world's caught up or catching up
they're not waiting i would say
parenthetically
if we were sitting down we set a
bipartisan committee together and said
okay
we're going to decide what we do in
terms of government providing for free
education
i wonder whether we'd think as we did in
the 20th century
that 12 years is enough in the 21st
century
i doubt it
12 years is no longer enough today
to compete with the rest of the world in
the 21st century
that's why my american family's plan
guarantees four additional years of
public education for every person in
america
starting as early as we can
the great universities in this country
have conducted studies of the
last 10 years it shows that adding two
years of universal high quality
preschool
for every three-year-old and
four-year-old no matter what background
they come from
puts them in the position to be able to
compete
all the way through 12 years and
increases exponentially their
prospect of graduating and going on
beyond graduation
research chose when a young child goes
to school not day care
they're far more likely to graduate from
high school
and go to college or something after
high school
when you add two years of free community
college on top of that
you begin to change the dynamic
we can do that
and we'll increase pell grants and
invest in historical black colleges
universities
tribal colleges minority serving
institutions
the reason is they don't have the
endowments
but their students are just as capable
of learning about cyber security
just as capable of learning about
metallurgy met
all the things that are going on that
provide those jobs of the future
jill is a community college professor
who teaches today as first lady
she's long said
she's long
[Applause]
if i've heard it once i've heard it a
thousand times
joe any country that out educates us
is going to out-compete us
she'll be deeply involved in leading
this effort thank you jill
second thing we need american
families plan will provide access to
quality affordable child
care we
[Applause]
when guarantee proposing on legislation
we guarantee
that low middle-income families will pay
no more than
seven percent of their income for
high-quality
care for children up to the age of five
the most hard-pressed working families
won't have to spend a dime
third the american family's plan will
finally provide up to 12 weeks of paid
leave and medical leave family media
they're one of the few industrial
countries in the world
[Applause]
no one should have to choose between a
job
and a paycheck are taking care of
themselves and their loved ones their
parent or spouse or child
and fourth the american family plan puts
directly into the pockets of millions of
americans
in march we expanded tax credit for
every child
in a family up to three thousand dollars
per child
if they're under six years of age i'm
assuming under over six years of age
and three thousand six hundred dollars
for children
over six years of age with two parents
two kids that's
seventy two hundred dollars in the
pockets they're gonna help take care of
your family
and that will help more than 65 million
children and help cut child care poverty
in half
and we can afford it
so we did that in the
in the last piece of legislation we
passed
but let's extend that child care tax
credit at least through the end of 2025.
the american rescue plan lowered health
care premiums for nine million americans
who buy their coverage under the
affordable care act
i know that's really popular this side
of the aisle
but let's make that provision permanent
so their premiums don't go back up
in addition to my family's plan i'm
going to work with congress to address
this year
other critical priorities for american
families
the affordable care act has been a
lifeline for millions of americans
protecting people with pre-existing
conditions protecting women's health
and the pandemic has demonstrated how
badly how badly it's needed
let's lower deductibles for working
families on the affordable care and
affordable care act
and let's lower prescription drug costs
we know how to do this
[Applause]
the last president had that as objective
we all know how outrageously expensive
drugs are in america in fact we pay
the highest prescription drug prices of
anywhere in the world right here in
america
nearly three times for the same drug
nearly three times what other countries
pay
we have to change that and we can let's
do what we talked about for all the
years i was down here in this
in this body in congress
let's give medicare the power to save
hundreds of billions
by negotiating lower drug prescription
prices
by the way it won't just
won't just tell people on medicare or
prescription drug costs for everyone
and the money we save which is billions
of dollars
can go to strengthen the affordable care
act and expand medicare coverage
benefits without costing taxpayers an
additional penny
it's within our power to do it let's do
it now
we've talked about it long enough
democrats and republicans
let's get it done this year this is all
about a simple premise
health care should be a right not a
privilege in america
so
how do we pay for my jobs and family
plan
i made it clear we can do it without
increasing the deficits
let's start with what i will not do
i will not impose any tax increase on
people making less
than four hundred thousand dollars it's
but it's time for corporate america
and the wealthiest one percent of
americans have just begun to pay their
fair share
just their fair share
sometimes i have arguments with my
friends in the democratic party
i think you should be able to become a
billionaire and a millionaire but
pay your fair share a recent study shows
that 55 of the nation's biggest
corporations
paid zero federal tax last year
those 55 corporations made in excess
of 40 billion dollars in profit
a lot of companies also evade taxes
through tax havens in switzerland and
bermuda
and the cayman islands and they benefit
from tax loopholes and deductions
for offshoring jobs and shifting profits
overseas
it's not right we're going to reform
corporate taxes
so they pay their fair share and help
pay for the public investments
their businesses will benefit from as
well
[Applause]
we're going to reward work not just
wealth
we take the top tax bracket for the
wealthiest one percent of americans
those making over 400 000 or more
back up to where it was when george w
bush was president
when he started 39.6
that's where it was when george w was
president
we're going to get rid of the loopholes
allow americans to make more than a
million dollars a year
and pay a lower tax rate
on their capital gains in americans who
receive a paycheck
we're only going to affect three tenths
of one percent of all americans by that
action three tenths of one percent
and the rs is going to crack down on
millionaires and billionaires who cheat
on their taxes
it's estimated to be billions of dollars
i think tanks are left right and center
i'm not looking to punish anybody
but i will not add a tax burden
additional tax burden of the middle
class in this country
they're already paying enough i believe
what i propose is fair
fiscally responsible and it raises
revenue to pay for the plans i propose
and will create millions of jobs
that will grow the economy and enhance
our financial standing in the country
when you hear someone say
they don't want to raise taxes on the
wealthiest one percent
or corporate america ask them
whose taxes you want to raise instead
who's there going to cut
the big tax cut of 2017.
remember it was supposed to pay for
itself that was how it was sold
and generate vast economic growth
instead it added two trillion dollars to
the deficit
it was a huge windfall for corporate
america
and those at the very top instead of
using the tax saving to raise wages and
invest in research
and development it poured billions of
dollars into the pocket of ceos
in fact the pay gap between ceos and
their workers is now
among the largest in history according
to one study ceos make 320 times
what the average worker in their
corporation makes used to be in the
below 100. the pandemic has
only made things worse 20 million
americans lost their job in the pandemic
working the middle class americans at
the same time
roughly 650 billionaires in america
saw their net worth increase by more
than one trillion dollars in the same
exact period let me say it again
650 people increased their wealth by
more than one trillion dollars during
this pandemic
and they're now worth more than four
trillion dollars
my fellow americans trickle down
trickle down economics has never worked
and it's time to grow the economy from
the bottom in the middle out
you know there's a broad consensus of
economists left right and center and
they agree
what i'm proposing will help create
millions of jobs and generate historic
economic growth
these are among the highest values
investments we can make as a nation
i've often said our greatest strength
is the power of our example not just the
example of our power
my conversation with world leaders and
i've spoken over 38 40 of them now
i've made it known i've made it known
that america is back you know what they
say
the comment i hear most of all from them
they say we see america's back
but for how long but for how long
my fellow americans we have to show not
just that we're back
but we're back to stay and that we
aren't going to go
alone
we're going to do it by leading with our
allies
no one nation can deal with all the
crises of our time
from terrorism to nuclear proliferation
mass migration
cyber security climate change as well as
experience what we're experiencing now
pandemics
there's no wall high enough to keep any
virus out
and our own vaccine supply as it grows
to meet our needs and we're meeting them
we'll become an arsenal for vaccines for
other countries
just as america's arsenal for democracy
for the world
and the consequence influenced the world
[Applause]
but every american will have access
before that occur every american of
access
to be fully covered by covet 19 from the
vaccines we have
look the climate crisis is not our fight
alone it's a global fight
the united states accounts as all of you
know less than 15
of carbon emissions the rest of the
world accounts for 85
that's why i kept my commitment to
rejoin the paris accord because if we do
everything
perfectly it's not going to only matter
i kept my commitment to convene a
climate summit right here in america
with all the major economies of the
world
china russia india european union
i said i'd do it my first 100 days i
want to be very
blunt about it i had
my attempt was to make sure
that the world could see there was a
consensus
that we are at an inflection point in
history and kent's consensus
is if we act to save the planet we can
create millions of jobs
and economic growth and opportunity to
raise the standard of living almost
everyone around the world if you watched
any of it and you were all busy i'm sure
you didn't have much time
that's what virtually every nation said
even the ones that aren't doing their
fair share
the investments i propose tonight also
advance the foreign policy
in my view that benefits the middle
class that means making sure every
nation
plays by the same rules in the global
economy including china
my discussions in my discussion with
president xi i told him
we welcome the competition we're not
looking for conflict
but i made absolutely clear
that we will defend america's interest
across the board
america will stand up to unfair trade
practices and undercut american workers
in american industries like subsidies
from state to state-owned operations and
enterprises
and the theft of american technology
intellectual property
i also told president xi that will
maintain a strong military presence in
the indo-pacific
just as we do for nato and europe not to
start a conflict but to prevent one
[Applause]
i told them what i've said to many world
leaders that america will not
back away from our commitments our
commitment to human rights and
fundamental freedoms
and to our alliances i pointed out to
him
no responsible american president could
remain
silent when basic human rights are being
so blatantly violated
an american president president has to
represent the essence of what our
country stands for
america is an idea the most unique idea
in history
we are created all of us equal
it's who we are and we cannot walk away
from that principle
and in fact say we're dealing with the
american idea
with regard to russia i know a concern
some of you
but i made very clear to putin that
we're not going to seek
excuse me escalation
but their actions will have consequences
they turn out to be true and they turned
out to be true
so i responded directly proportionately
to russia's interference in our
elections and the cyber attacks on our
government and our business
they did both of these things
and i told them we would respond and we
had
but we can also cooperate when it's our
mutual interest
we did it when we extended the new start
treaty on nuclear arms
and we're working to do it on climate
change but
he understands we will respond
on iran and north korea nuclear programs
that present serious threats to american
security and the security of the world
we're going to be working closely with
our allies to address
the threats posed by both of these
countries through
through diplomacy as well as stern
deterrence
and american leadership means ending the
forever war in afghanistan
we have
we have without hyperbole the greatest
fighting force in history of the world
i'm the first president of 40 years who
knows what it means to have a son
serving in a war zone
today we have service members serving in
the same war zone as their parents did
we have service members in afghanistan
who are not yet born
on 9 11. the war in afghanistan as we
remember the debates here
were never meant to be
multi-generational undertakings
of nation-building we went to
afghanistan to get terrorists
the terrorists attacked us on 9 11.
and we said we would follow osama bin
laden to the gates of hell
to do it if you've been in the upper
conor valley you've kind of seen the
gates of hell
and we delivered justice to bin laden we
degraded the terrorist threat
of al-qaeda in afghanistan and after 20
years of value
valor and sacrifice it's time to bring
those troops home
look
even as we do will maintain over the
horizon capacity to suppress
future threats to the homeland make no
mistake
in 20 years terrorists has terrorism has
metastasized
the threat has evolved way beyond
afghanistan
those of you in the intelligence
committees the foreign relations
committee defense committees
you know well we have to remain vigilant
against the threats to the united states
wherever they come from
al qaeda and isis are in yemen syria
somalia
other places in africa in the middle
east and beyond
and we won't ignore what our
intelligence agencies have
determined to be the most lethal
terrorist threat to the homeland today
white supremacy is terrorism we're not
going to ignore that either
my fellow americans look we have to come
together
to heal the soul of this nation it was
nearly a year ago before her father's
funeral
when i spoke with gianna floyd george
floyd's young daughter
she's a little tight so i was kneeling
down to talk to her
so i could look her in the eye she
looked at me she said
my daddy changed the world
well after the conviction of george
floyd's murderer
we can see how right she was if
if we have the courage to act as a
congress
we've all seen the name and justice on
the neck of black americans
now is our opportunity to make some real
progress
the vast majority of men and women
wearing a uniform and a badge serve our
communities and they serve them
honorably
i know them i know they want
i know
[Applause]
they want to help meet this moment as
well
my fellow americans we have to come
together
to rebuild trust between law enforcement
and the people they serve
to root out systemic racism in our
criminal justice system
and to enact police reform in george
floyd's name
that passed the house already i know
republicans have their own ideas
and are engaged in a very productive
discussions with democrats in the senate
we need to work together to find a
consensus but let's get it done next
month
by the first anniversary of george
floyd's death
the country supports this and congress
should act should act we have a giant
opportunity to bend the arc of the moral
universe toward justice real justice
and with the plans outlined tonight we
have a real chance to
root out systemic racism that plagues
america
and american lives in other ways a
chance to deliver real equity
good jobs good schools affordable
housing
clean air clean water being able to
generate wealth and pass it down
to generations because you have an
access to purchase a house
real opportunities in the lives of more
americans black white latino asian
americans native americans
look i also want to thank the united
states senate
for voting 94 to 1 to pass the covet 19
hate crimes act to protect
asian american and pacific islanders
you acted decisively
you can see on television the
viciousness of the hate crimes
we've seen over the past year this past
year and for too long
i urge the house to do the same and send
that legislation to my desk
which i will gladly anxiously sign
i also hope congressman get to my desk
the equality act to protect lgbtq
americans
we're all transgender americans watching
at home especially
young people you're so brave i want you
to know your president has your back
another thing let's authorize the
violence against women act which has
been law for 27 years
27 years ago i wrote it
it'll close the act that has to be
authorized now we'll close the boyfriend
loophole
to keep guns out of the hands of abusers
the court order said this is an abuser
you can't own a gun
it's to close that loophole that existed
you know it's estimated that
50 women are shot and killed
by an intimate partner every month in
america
50 a month let's pass it and save some
lives
[Applause]
and i need to i need not tell anyone
this but gun violence has become an
epidemic in america
the flag at the white house was still
flying at half-mast
for the eight victims of the mass
shooting in georgia
when 10 more lives were taken in a mass
shooting in colorado
and in the week in between those two
events
250 other americans were shot dead in
the streets of america
250 shot dead
i know how hard it is to make progress
on this issue
in the 90s we passed universal
background checks
a ban on assault weapons in
high-capacity magazines that hold a
hundred rounds
that can be fired off in seconds
we beat the nra mass shootings and gun
violence decline
check out the report over 10 years but
in the early 20 to 2000
the law expired we've seen daily blood
since i'm not saying if the law
continued we wouldn't see bloodshed
more than two weeks ago in the rose
garden surrounded by
some of the bravest people i know the
survivors and families who lost loved
ones to gun violence
i laid out several of the department of
justice
actions that are being taken to impact
in this epidemic
one of them is banning so-called ghost
guns
these are homemade guns built from a kit
that includes directions how to finish
the firearm
the parts have no serial numbers
so they show up at crime scenes and they
can't be traced
the bars of these ghost gun kits aren't
required to pass any background check
anyone from a criminal or terrorist
could buy this kit and within 30 minutes
have a weapon that's lethal but no more
and i'll do everything in my power to
protect the american people for this
epidemic of gun violence but it's time
for congress to act as well
look
[Applause]
i don't want to become confrontational
but we need more senate republicans to
join the overall majority of democratic
colleagues and
close the loopholes required in
background check purchases of guns
we need a ban on assault weapons in
high-capacity magazines
don't tell me it can't be done we did it
before and it worked
talk to most responsible gun owners and
hunters
they'll tell you there's no possible
justification for having a hundred
rounds
and a weapon
what do you think deer wearing kevlar
vests
what's they'll tell you that they're too
many people a day
who are able to buy a gun but shouldn't
be able to buy a gun
these kinds of reasonable reforms have
overwhelming support from the american
people including many gun owners
the country supports reforms and
congress should act
this shouldn't be a red or blue issue
and no amendment to the constitution is
absolute
you can't yell fire in a crowd of
theater
from the very beginning there were
certain guns
weapons that could not be owned by
americans
certain people could not own those
weapons
ever we're not changing the constitution
we're being reasonable i think this is
not a democrat or republican issue i
think is an american issue
and here's what else we can do
immigration has always been essential to
america
let's end our exhausting war over
immigration
for more than 30 years politicians have
talked about immigration reform
and we've done nothing about it it's
time to fix it
on day one of my presidency i kept my
commitments on a comprehensive
immigration bill to the united states
congress
if you believe we need to secure the
border pass it because it has
a lot of money for high-tech border
security
if you believe in a pathway to
citizenship pass it
it's over 11 million undocumented folks
the vast majority of here
overstaying visas pass it
we can actually if you actually want to
solve a problem
i've sent a bill to take a close look at
it
we have to also have to get the root
problem of why people are fleeing
particularly this
to our southern border from guatemala
honduras and el salvador
the violence the corruption the gangs
the political instability hunger
hurricanes earthquakes
natural disasters when i was president
my president when i was vice president
president asked me to focus on providing
help needed to address the root causes
of migration
and it helped keep people in their own
countries instead of being forced to
leave
the plan was working but the last
administration decided
it was not worth it i'm restoring the
program and asked vice president harris
to lead our diplomatic effort to take
care of this
i have absolute confidence to get the
job done
now look if you don't like my plan
let's at least pass what we all agree on
congress needs to pass legislation this
year to finally secure protection for
dreamers
the young people have only known
america as their home
and permanent protection for
immigrants who are here on temporary
protective status who came from
countries
that set by man-made and natural made
violence
and disaster
as well as the pathway to citizens for
farm workers who put food on our tables
look
immigrants have done so much for america
during this pandemic
and throughout our history the country
supports immigration reform
we should act let's argue over it let's
debate it
let's act and if we truly want us to
restore
the soul of america we need to protect
the sacred right to vote
most people
[Applause]
more people vote in the last
presidential election than any time in
american history
in the middle of the worst pandemic ever
it should be celebrated instead it's
being attacked
congress should pass h.r 1 and the john
lewis voting rights act
and send it to my desk right away
the country supports it and congress
should act
now
look in conclusion as we gather here
tonight the image of a violent mob
assaulting this capital desecrating our
democracy remained vivid in all our
minds
lives were put at risk many of your
lives
lives were lost extraordinary courage
was summoned
the insurrection was an existential
crisis a test
on whether our democracy could survive
and it did
but the struggle is far from over the
question of whether our democracy
will long endure as both ancient and
urgent
as old as our republic still
vital today can our democracy deliver on
its promise
that all of us created equal in the
image of god had a chance to lead lives
of dignity
respect and possibility can our
democracy
deliver the most to the most pressing
needs of our people
can our democracy overcome the lies
anger hate and fears
that have pulled us apart america's
adversaries the autocrats of the world
are betting we can't and i promise you
they're betting we can't
they believe we're too full of anger and
division and rage
they look at the images of the mob that
assaulted the capital as proof
that the sun is sending out american
democracy but they're wrong
you know it i know it but we have to
prove them wrong
we have to prove democracy still works
that our government still works and we
can
deliver for our people in our first
hundred days together
we've acted restore people's faith in
democracy to deliver
we're vaccinating the nation we're
creating hundreds of thousands of new
jobs
we're delivering real results to people
they can see it feel it their own lives
opening doors of opportunity
guaranteeing some more fairness and
justice that's the essence of america
that's democracy in action our
constitution opens with the words as
trade as it sounds
we the people it was time remember that
we the people
are the government you and i
not some force in a distant capital not
some powerful force that we have no
control over
it's us it's we the people
in another era when our democracy was
tested franklin roosevelt reminded us
in america we do our part we all
do our part that's all i'm asking
that we do our part all of us if we do
that
we will meet the center challenge of the
age by proving that democracy is durable
and strong
autocrats will not win the future we
will america will
and the future belongs to america
as i stand here tonight before you in a
new and vital hour of life and democracy
of our nation
and i can say with absolute confidence i
have never been more
confident or optimistic about america
not because i'm president
because what's happening with the
american people
we've stared into the abyss of
insurrection and autocracy
pandemic and pain and we the people did
not
flinch at the very moment our
adversaries were certain we'd pull apart
and fail we came together we united
with light and hope we summoned the new
strength
new resolve to position us to win the
competition of 21st century
on our way to a union more perfect
more prosperous and more just
as one people one nation and one america
folks as i told every world leader i've
ever met with over the years
it's never ever ever been a good bet to
bet against america
and it still isn't we're the united
states of america
there's not a single thing nothing
nothing beyond our capacity
we can do whatever we set our mind to if
we do it together
so let's begin to get together
god bless you all and may god protect
our troops
thank you for your patience
thank you
love that
watch out for that
[Music]
hmm
and by the way
i knew
yes
okay
okay
foreign
good
foreign
thank you
hmm
you know who called me today
so i don't know how to reach out to you
but i have the experience
my name is
um
and they believe derek chavin is
innocent of murdering george floyd
now they're standing in the way of
congress trying to deliver relief to
working people
last month not a single elected
republican
voted to send relief checks to
struggling americans in the middle of a
pandemic
so it's on us as democrats and
progressives
to meet the gravity of the moment and
history will judge our actions
the single mom in the bronx working two
jobs to make ends meet
that's who i'm thinking about i want to
be able to say at the end of this
congressional session
that congress has done everything we
possibly could
to make her life better that's what our
movement
the progressive movement is guided by
our movement is latino we are
asian we are black we are white we are a
beautiful mix of ethnicities and
cultures
all over the globe who are demanding
justice and humanity
we are a continuation of the civil
rights movement
we are led by organizers and
organizations like stacy abrams
zakiyah ansari jesse hagopian and the
sunrise movement
elected leaders who have shifted the
narrative like elizabeth warren
bernie sanders aoc ayanna rashida ilhan
corey and mondaire
and we are capable of big powerful
transformative change
it is entirely possible to meet the
climate crisis
with a big visionary investment in jobs
jobs that begin in our most neglected
and red line communities
we must build a civilian climate corps
that employs millions of americans to do
good work of transforming our energy
system
in our society we can create jobs and
solve the climate crisis at the same
time
we need a green new deal for public
housing as my colleague and friend
congresswoman ocasio-cortez has proposed
we can repair and transform run down
neglected apartments in new york and
neighborhoods
all across america we can make public
housing better
more healthy and more safe while turning
every public housing development
into a source of clean energy we need a
green new deal for cities as my sister
corey bush has proposed
and we need a green new deal for public
schools
every part of our society must become
part of the answer
because this crisis is urgent we can
create those new
green jobs and we must make the jobs
people already have better
that's what the thrive act is all about
which will create
15 million green union jobs
and we have to build up labor unions too
that's why congress must pass the pro
act
to protect the right to organize akwa do
away with so-called right-to-work laws
make it easier for workers to unionize
and even let
independent contractors bargain
collectively
we also badly need a 15 minimum wage
not phased in in 10 years from now but
today
and if we need to get rid of the
filibuster to do that
that's absolutely what we must do
if this pandemic has shown us anything
is that the american worker is the
backbone of our country
it might not be a popular idea around
washington but the rest of us know
that grocery store workers nurses
teachers and transit workers
are all more essential than anything
wall street does
in fact there's a whole economy of
workers
mostly women and disproportionately
women of color
who are doing the hard essential work of
caring for our moms and dads
looking after our kids and healing the
sick
these workers represent the care economy
unfortunately
workers in the care economy are often
underpaid abused or neglected by
employers
they're not unionized so there's no one
there to speak up for them
when they face unsafe working conditions
or meager wages
the care economy is already enormous and
is only going to become
more important in the future we need to
invest in
paid family and medical leave we need to
make
child care universal and exemplary and
we need
living wages and benefits for care
workers who provide the services we all
need
i call it the care for all agenda as we
must center care as the rebirth of our
nation
because caring is the entire point of
what our economy should do
it should be about caring for one
another not just extracting profits from
working people for wall street
the proposals that president biden has
put forward over the last few weeks
would represent important steps but
don't go as big as we truly need in
order to solve
the crises of jobs climate and care
we need to think bigger because now is
the time to address the burning crisis
of structural racism in our country
every single time i have to watch a
video of a black man
or a brown kid die at the hands of
police violence
a little piece of me dies too i am
connected to every black man in america
like them my ancestors were kidnapped
from africa
robbed of their language and stripped of
their culture religion and god
and we continue to be redlined and
killed by the police
i have one message for law